we all know we have a problem with women
of color in one corner and white women
in another corner if there's one thing
Jada pinkett-smith isn't afraid to do on
red Tabletalk its taking on those
difficult conversations and that's just
what they did on Monday tackling the
topic of white privilege and Prejudice
during the discussion between Pinkett
Smith her 18 year old daughter willow
her mom Adrienne and several guests
including activist Rachel Cargill the
actress noted the importance of allowing
white women to be allies to women of
color as women of color we really have
to recognize when white women come in to
help that we make room for absolutely
because it's been a couple of times like
if the Anne Hathaway
it is trusted yeah beliefs oh I get it
but at some point where are we as black
women going to be able to recognize an
ally Hathaway caught some heat last
April when she posted this photo of Nia
Wilson a woman of color who was murdered
to her Instagram with the caption white
people including me including you must
take into the marrow of our privileged
bones the truth that all black people
fear for their lives daily in America
and have done so for generations the
post sparked so much controversy that
Hathaway decided to deactivate the
comment section it's not a matter of
black women saying hey we're open to you
being and I lied to us that's not the
case white women showing up in saying
you have a righteous anger you're
allowed to be livid at the things that
we have imposed on you over history
either they're the hero or a victim they
ran
they rarely take responsibility Pinkett
Smith made sure to point out the
difficulties some white women face when
they try to help women of color I just
know that we can have a certain kind of
like why are you here all I'm saying
though we need them they need us we need
your native German we all need each
other we have to be able to fit in a bit
of vulnerability to allow for a certain
kind of healing to occur ET recently sat
down with the 47 year old and she opened
up about why her chats at the red table
are so important what is it about the
red table that made it work because it
is a sensation now it's not just like
people are like oh yeah Jada did this
thing people are going to the red table
mm-hmm how did you know I did it I had
no idea I had no idea I just you know it
was a it was a concept that I thought
about years ago when I think Willow was
maybe 11 and we did it that one Mother's
Day a one-off we did one red table
because I was like wow you know it'd be
great to see three generations of women
to sit down and have real conversation I
want to do this as a way to celebrate
motherhood and so I did it from Mother's
Day when willow was 11 and then that was
it I just knew that there were people
that were ready to have different kinds
of conversations and I was ready to have
those conversations mommy was ready and
so as willow was it scary being so
authentic because that's what the red
table is very authentic and that's scary
you know what I have to be honest with
you at this point in my life I'm just
like what else is there to do like why
aren't we talking in a way which you
know sharing and offering ourselves in
the way that we can help each other crow
help each other have the lives that we
want and that's really what made me say
listen this is ridiculous everybody
holding information all close to the
chest we really all have information for
each other we would just talk to each
other we would know we're not in this
game alone we're all going through the
same thing it ain't nothing unique is
not nothing different
[Music]